last time you were on the show you
talked about this lesbian exorcism you
participated in do you still maintain
that you successfully did a so-called
lesbian exorcism on a woman please don't
insult me David uh there is really
nothing mysterious about exorcism it's
simply an act of repentance and allowing
the Holy Spirit to come into your life
there's no particular ritual for it
they're simply renouncing your sins in
fact I could leave you David if you
would be willing to come to Faith in
Jesus Christ to renounce your sins and
get the devil out of your heart you can
do that anytime and invite the spirit of
Jesus Christ to move into your heart and
Rule your life and so the lesbian
exorcism you've done one of these or
more than one you know offhand I don't
keep statistics on that thing but I have
certainly prayed with more than one
homosexual to renounce their sins and
invite Jesus to rule their life